et la guerre à distance entre à
l'application à tik tok et les états
unis continuent leur réseau social
n'hésite pas à répliquer en annonçant
vouloir porter plainte contre le pays
dirigé par donald trump a dans la
semaine à venir
l entreprise chinoise accuse les
etats-unis de je cite s'immiscer dans
des négociations entre groupes privés
tik tok répond donc aux menaces
d'interdiction du président américain
on le rappelle l'administration trump
accuse depuis à des mois l'application
d'espionner ses utilisateurs
et justement pour en parler nous sommes
avec pierre-yves à l'avocat spécialiste
du numérique
bonsoir tu y arrives à la merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur rtl france alors
on l'a dit un l'application chinoise va
déposer un recours en justice demain
pour contester le décret d'interdiction
signé par donald trump
qu'est ce que cela peut changer pour
pour tik tok
alors qu'est ce que cela peut changer
quand il toque tout puisque
l'application ne pourrait plus être
utilisé au d'été du lit en tout cas il y
aurait une interdiction pour tous les
entreprises américaines d'effectuer des
transactions ça veut dire que le
téléchargement qui stocke ne pourrait
plus être effectués alors pratiquement
c'est très compliqué à faire parce qu'il
faudrait en réalité que les déforme
je pense à l'app store je pense à
android donc enlève c'est cette
application on ne peut pas interdire on
ne peut pas m'enlever de chaque
ordinateur fortage de chaque de chaque
téléphone l'application elle-même
maintenant il est clair que ça va être
extrêmement compliqué quand ils top de
fonctionner et ça va être aussi
peut-être également une très grande des
beats dans le pied des autres
prisonniers lesquels puisque je rappelle
petite toque et est impacté mais
également au chat
c'était celle de l'énorme mastodonte
chinois qui est impliqué comme maison
mère derrière et que le fait de le dater
d'hier de ou chat dans les projections
c'est 30% de apple qui qui risque d'être
impacté donc 30% d'apple l'iphone en
moins on imagine très bien que cette
cette appli que l'interdiction
d'applications avril aurait des
conséquences tout à fait détonnant qui
ont internet qui semble un espèce de
baky début de balkanisation deux de
l'internet en permettant à chaque pays
d'avoir l'internet spécifique qui est
totalement sans délai ni accuse
injustement l'application tic tac
d'espionner ses utilisateurs pourquoi
les états unis justement pense que tik
tok espionne ses utilisateurs ont-ils
des preuves apparemment pas plus que pas
plus que ça même le sénat américain qui
interdit également aux fonctionnaires us
de télécharger l'application ou la
chambre des représentants non de
d'éléments particuliers on a aujourd'hui
simplement des affirmations de cette
urgence nationale qui serait qu'ils
étaient invoquées aujourd'hui par
l'administration trump cours pour sortir
ce executive order du cidc décret
d'interdiction du 6 août
tik tok n'espionne pas davantage les
internautes américains que les
entreprises américaines et mr que
facebook ou twitter d'autres ou d'autres
d'autres plateformes
donc tout ça est un prétexte bien
évidemment c'est rejouer ce qu'on
appelle l'élite régionale et economics
powers act qui permet au président
américain de l'utiliser sur le sait
cette arme de destruction massive qui
est un décret d'interdiction qui avait
déjà employé rappelons-nous en 2017 avec
le music bas et il avait été retoquée
d'ailleurs par par les juridictions
américaines qu'il avait déclaré
inconstitutionnelle par c'est pas une
première pour l'administration problème
d'essayer de montrer les muscles
on est manifestement dans une bataille
diplomatique pour essayer de de
contraindre les chinois a pas trop
pavillon américain
mais mais vraiment une d'une manière
absolument juridiquement au très
contestable alors l'application s'est
aussi engagée
une campagne de relations publiques avec
un nouveau site web pour combattre les
rumeurs
jusqu'où cette guerre peut aller
concrètement c'est bien peu aller comme
je parlais de balkanisation ça veut dire
que l'élément les chinois car c'est déjà
pour beaucoup les applications
américaine l'un d'eux l'un on l'a vu à
l'interdît qui déjà tik tok et 70
applications similaires déjà depuis de
keke quelques mois donc on peut on peut
on peut aller à ce rythme là avec chaque
pays interdisant aux grilles de sa
volonté à sa nombre alors avec une
possibilité juridique ou pas de le faire
mais en fait un peu car avec des
peut-être l'aider tentation de faire en
interne est un peu maison et d'essayer
de chaque fois prié des applications
pourquoi pas au meilleur prix parce
qu'en réalité c'est ça qui est sous
tendu dans le temps c'est de ce bras de
fer qui toquent administration preuve en
réalité et rob veut faire rentrer tictoc
états unis sous le pavillon américain en
soit dans racheté par microsoft ou voir
twitter
et là on entend maintenant ses efforts
acle qui tuerait le tueur est le dernier
os peut-être c'est en tout cas avec
l'approbation de saint-prime m
donc tout ça est une affaire de gros
sous et en tout cas pas très et pas très
engageant pour la liberté d'expression
et pour la liberté de commerce parce
qu'en réalité au des cas du lycée
peut-être qu'ils premier amendement qui
risque d'être des travaux quai par le
recours que twitter va faire contre le
que la tic toc d'affaires devant les
juridictions américaines pour essayer de
l'empêcher cet executive order de tartre
à l'application qui s'étend aujourd'hui
n'apparaît pas comme un bouc émissaire
au milieu de cette guerre commerciale
qui dure entre la chine et les états
unis depuis
depuis quelques années maintenant il y
avait moi ouailles avant aujourd'hui
yat-il toi qu'est-ce que tik tok est
aujourd'hui là au bon endroit au bon
moment
c'est un bouc émissaire j'avais
parfaitement résumé la situation on a
ses petites toi qui est extrêmement
populaire aujourd'hui des millions
d'utilisateurs
on a witch est également en oublient
qu'ils étaient très très une application
extrêmement important d utiliser part
dans le monde et notamment notamment en
chine
donc oui bien évidemment on a
aujourd'hui on essaie de taper sur son
tik tok pas je pensais que ça va faire
mal et elle pour essayer de faire entrer
la chine dans le rang pense pas que ça
soit vraiment la meilleure méthode est
en tout cas bien mal venu de la part
d'un d'un pays et états unis qui ne
respectent pas forcément non plus le les
données personnelles de c2c
d'internautes autant que l'europe par
exemple peut le faire avec le r j'étais
là les états unis sont bien évidemment
un mauvais élève et à mes élèves qui m'a
critiqué la chine bon là franchement
c'est pas très très très intéressant au
niveau
au niveau déontologie en tout cas on
sait que l'aller l'équipe n'a peu mais
ce n'est que peu de peu de peu de choses
à faire avec le business mais en
l'occurrence c'est une affaire de gros
sous et je crois et des denrées d'enjeux
politiques et diplomatiques
mais au total on peut craindre en tout
cas que ce soit l'internaute qui soit le
grand perdant une nouvelle fois et la
liberté d'expression également de de
cette affaire qui est absolument
scandaleuse parce qu'utiliser un décret
pour deux force utilisée l'urgence
nationale pour simplement des
affirmations qui n'ont absolument pas
démontré qu'ils sont en tout cas utilise
également des états unis largement pour
détourner les données personnelles de 2
des utilisateurs
tout ça n'est pas sa seule merci
beaucoup aux tirs et malin d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes avocat et
spécialiste du numérique merci beaucoup